it's a deadly game of hide and seek
along Ukraine's Eastern Front Line
Soldiers with the 26th Artillery Brigade
maneuver this 155 caliber German
Howitzer to its firing position
Russian forces are in the Eastern
outskirts of bahmoud
the cannon is targeting Russian Supply
and artillery positions beyond the town
it takes around 40 seconds for the shell
to reach its Target
the trajectory is adjusted after
information from drones and spotters
monitoring the target Zone
German mobile Howitzer has a range of
around 30 kilometers
and its weapons like this from the West
that have given the ukrainians a
Fighting Chance
back Undercover the men load more
charges and prepare to fire again
because it is a key Point our task is
the destruction of places where there is
a concentration of Manpower and
batteries of firing positions
we walk out through Fields crisscross
with mud churned by Ukrainian artillery
tanks pass us on the road into town
smoke Rises seconds after what we are
told was a Ukrainian anti-missile system
intercepting a Russian rocket
lines of Ukrainian foot soldiers head to
positions nearby
in Bahamut explosions echo through the
near empty streets
suddenly the scream of a jet fighter
overhead
[Music]
they're throwing all their forces at the
Town artillery air power even
helicopters are attacking our positions
they are approaching during night and
day and it's their elite units and
mercenaries there are no regular Russian
troops left here
few people remain here
bookshelves and beds hang mid-air
private lives intimate personal places
ripped apart
we are told two people remain buried
under the rubble of this apartment block
from
the selling never stops I stay here to
look after my mother she's old and frail
things have gone a lot worse
Western Weaponry has helped the
Ukrainian Army win back more territory
in a month than Russian forces took in
five
but the defense of bakmud remains one of
Ukraine's biggest challenges on the
Eastern Front Line
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera he's the
crane